a little bit about myself before we
start I'm from Argentina this is my
first conference outside South America
as both as a speaker and a sonnet in G
so I'm pretty excited about that
I work coding or researching different
things that move it we had a pool so I
talked with some of the guys here if you
want to find me on the internet those
are my github and to your profiles so if
you're wondering a little bit about
movie we are a software consultancy firm
we are basing nuts in Texas Uruguay
Argentina and Colombia we work on a lot
of different technologies languages we
build a lot of different things from
mobile apps to websites everything we
have our first Nadja slash react.js
apprenticeship on Austin we do that
periodically so if you are from Asti now
do you know someone from Austin that
might be interested in learning no js'
or eh is just check outside and see how
that's going
that's our to era so before we start I
would like to make one disclaimer this
was originally a one-hour long talk we
got a broad topic and I need to fit them
in 25 minutes so we're with me and some
things I hopefully will get through
everything so a lot of people asked me
to hit why not G as for machine learning
especially because there are a lot of
languages that are well known for being
performant they have better libraries
for data data science you know Python
has tensorflow cycle learn error has a
lot of math libraries as well as math
love I am sure like personally was that
after es6 came out i'm using javascript
for everything all my prototypes and
everything is JavaScript but if you want
to you know talk to your boss about
using javascript for machine learning
you should go with this explination
we do web development so it makes sense
for us to use no because we are running
using node we know like the ecosystem
package management management manager
and everything so it makes sense it was
easier to impor people because they
already know you
six they already know JavaScript they
already know everything but the
framework and a little bit about the
theory so you don't need to explain like
tensor flow distributed computing extra
things that you don't really need for
the case we all love javascript because
we are all here a JavaScript conference
nodejs has a lot of modules that are
great for different things like
normalizing your data working with our
output a lot of just general things we
have module for everything so that's
great but now the first one the right
tool for the job well for me work
because I'm not ingesting the amount of
data that Facebook or Instagram are
using or ingesting so for me make sense
it's working now in production some of
my products I had recommendation systems
and a lot of things working they're fine
don't have any CPU issues much so that's
pretty cool so yeah but I'm assuring
anyway I was trying to find like a
definition or something to put in here
and I found this quote from Arthur
Samuel he's like a pioneer in artificial
intelligent ingests he said it's a field
of study that gives the computer the
ability to learn without being explicit
program and this code is interesting to
me because it draws like the difference
between what's called weak AI and strong
AI week' it's you can think of that when
you code like a program to play chess or
checkers
so you said you get the impression that
the computer is actually thinking how to
beat you the computer will learn how to
play what actually it's just following a
set of steps that you program like well
like paths or brute-forcing or whatever
but strong AI it's when you program the
mechanism for the computer to learn to
do something it's up to the computer
what is next so that's kind of of what's
interesting and hard about machine
learning
I'm linking here to paper for from
artists animals about game theory and AI
that pretty girl article
about the difference between artificial
intelligence and machine learning so if
you want to check those out there are
different kinds of learning the first
one is unsupervised learning this type
of learning is when you have a bunch of
data that you know nothing about that
maybe you are mining from your
application from other places and you
just want to try to few a pattern or
some way to grow that data for example
when you have a bunch of data from your
users like their weight and their hate
and you just move things around and then
you feel hey so all these guys are size
s for t-shirts this our guy this all set
of guy medium and so forth
so that's kind of what this kind of
learning is about it's pretty commonly
used for data clustering and the
remaining and then we have supervised
learning which is more what we use which
is basically learning by examples you
will have some a set of data label data
so you know what the data means and
you're going to feed that data into your
model and your models going to try to
figure out the function that can learn
different patterns about that data so
basically that will help you to solve a
lot of different problems some problems
that supervised learning solve its
classification problems which is
basically you taking an input and you
need to classify the input among a set
of labels for example an input being a
picture and a set of labels being data
hot dog is not a hot dog our regression
problems when you try to predict some
continuous numeric output based on an
input for example trying to figure out
the price of a house based on the size
of the house or trying to predict your
score in a test based based on your
previous scores
that's a regression problem you had a
lot of different types of algorithms
there are yes and just are pre popular
but there are a bunch more I have been
using all these in JavaScript
for the first four key neared narrower
neighbors classification and regression
trees support vector machines Nevaeh's
this package called machine underscore
learning they have implementations of
all of them so if you want to just play
around you can download the package and
throw inputs and see what happens if you
are interested in how the algorithm
works you can just go to the source and
check the files they're fairly small and
it's pretty interesting to just research
and check how those are built and that
paper it's about like a brief
description of every one every single
algorithm I think there are more than
those why would you use one over the
other and just like use cases in general
pretty cool
so I'm going to try to do a brief
introduction to neural networks in
JavaScript I'm going to use this library
for the examples
it's called synaptic js how many of you
have heard about synaptic juice how many
of you are using synaptic JS like okay
so this library it's it's for me it's
great it works on both the browser and
nodejs it's my what scream by this guy
juan quezada which is from Argentina he
has a lot of examples pretty wiki with a
lot of examples everything's pretty well
documented so just kidding there was
just a breeze getting from trying to
learn machine learning in Python I was
rising issues like asking super noob
questions under well super polite like
yeah you need to dad or they were
explaining everything to me I was pretty
good so go and give him stars or asking
him questions ok this is another library
called
neat topic which started as a fork of
synaptic then they build their own thing
using back propagation and never
revolution so this is more for kind of
gaming things it's more performant but
if
you just want to play around with things
have recommend start with synaptic and
the mutiny topic so thing every time I
think of neural networks that that's the
picture that has in his mind like about
notes on our rows and that doesn't
really explain what they do but what
they basically do is split data into
groups so what you're trying to get the
computer to do with a neural network is
a computer good you split this data in
different groups it's like sure I split
the data into groups and then you have a
new entry point of your data and you can
just see where it fits and that's like
the classification of the regulation
problem so starting from like the basic
unit of a neural network obviously a
neuron I won't draw the parallelism
between this kind of Neverland and the
real neurons because I really don't know
no one's actually work well I don't know
I know how this works
yeah anyone basically it's composed of
different parts we have this arrows
coming into the neuron which is the red
dot rather this imp these arrows are
called synapses they could be an output
from another neuron adjust your input
every single one of these synapses or
the arrows are a value which is your
input and they are all multiplied by a
weight that would at first it's random
and the whole thing of machine learning
especially in never-never is just fine
in the weight that makes sense for
george data to get the input the output
that you want then all neural networks
besides their inputs they have one
extreme bill called bias which is always
one and it has his own weight and this
bias what it does is ensure that even if
all the inputs are zero you're still
going to get some kind of output that's
why that's one eye has also run the
weight assigned to that then the neuron
has
an active action an activation function
that we're going to see in a couple
slides after this one and then you have
the synapses going out of the neuron
that could be your final output or it
could be the input of the next one
so the activation functions but they do
basically scrubbing all the inputs from
the neuron they add them together the
inputs of the neuron are basically your
inputs or the input of the of the or do
put of the previous no no run multiplied
by the weight the activation function
grabs all the inputs add them together
and then use that as an input for for
itself
synaptic GS by default uses logistic
sigmoid functions which basically Maps
every budget that you use as an input
between zero and one that's basically
what it does if you want to know more
about like the theory I will link some
papers there and some unanswering Cora
that was pretty well explained there are
some more activation functions I'm
playing with rectified linear you need
now a lot I've been used your true and I
know nap topic has even more but Sigma
it's pretty popular and you don't really
need to change that unless you you
notice that your use case is not like
working so you can play around with the
functions and trying to see what it's
better for your use case but starting
with Sigma it's terrifying
so I never long come perform these for
different operations they can project
they can activate they can propagate and
then can gate project is basically
setting a synapse between two neurons
that's the red one is projecting into
the blue one they can activate that when
they grab all the inputs add them
together I'm called the sigmoid function
with that value they can propagate which
is the actual training of the of the
neuron that's when you you said you get
an output from the neuron
that wasn't what you expect her so you
propagate back the error based on what
you really expect there and that's going
to change the weights of all the
synapses back like until to the first
input neuron and that's what's called
back propagation and that's how they
finally they can get that's an operation
that's not pretty common it's just for
one kind of neural network that if we
have time we're going to see later yeah
this is a small example on synaptic how
you can create this neural network based
on two neurons we create two neurons
amb we project a to be that the synapses
between those and then B has an output
then we activate a with 0.5 the when we
do that a sense through the synapse 0.5
times random wait first and then we
activate B be grafts that output from a
perform the sigmoid activation function
we get like a lot of random data because
we are not really doing anything so if
we wanted to Train B to output 0 every
time that a activates with 1 this is how
we do it we do the same thing that
before create the two neurons we project
one switch to the other one we set up a
learning rate that will be important for
all propagation and then we have a for
loop that that's our training session
this training session has 20,000 it
iterations and on each iteration does
the same thing called a activate one
then activates B we don't care what bees
at this moment but like what the Abu
Dhabi is because we are going to
propagate that error so we say every
time we activate I a you should
propagate B with zero so what we are
saying here is every time that a is one
B which should be 0 and the propagate
will change the way it's like 20,000
times until we get closer and closer to
0 so when the training session session
ends we activate a we want we
that something pretty close to zero that
you could do a map from and that the
training of your first tuner on base no
network obviously on Rihanna right no
but you will need like a bunch of
different and neurons and layers and
this is how real neural novel looks you
can see like why who why usually use a
number of hidden layers and how many
neurons the hidden layer should have
based on those and there is a paper
rather Stack Exchange
link that explains that very well so
let's build a small neural network as an
example you are I guess
all familiar with the XOR operation what
it does basically takes two inputs if
the two inputs are equal the output 0
they are different they are both 1 so we
are going to train a neural network to
perform this operation so based on this
on this picture we can say ok so we have
two inputs on our vector so it's going
to be 2 now runs on the input layer we
have one output on a vector so it's
going to be one neuron on the open layer
and then we usually had at least one
hidden layer you could not have any but
that's just for super simple
classification problems and at that
point you might not need no longer word
I mean you can use them but it defeats
the purpose
well yeah let's use one hand layer and
the rule of thumb or selecting how many
neurons should be in the final layer and
the hidden layer it's basically the mean
between the neurons from the output
layer and the input layer so in this
case too so going on synaptic again we
import the layer object the network and
the network object we create or three
layers ignore that three right there
that should be achoo
but then we project one layer to the
other one the input layer to a hiding
layer they hide a layer to the upper
layer and then we create the network
using the network on structure so we
have never it looks something like this
- runs from the input one of them on the
output or hidden layer and this is how
our training looks we are going to use a
learning rate of 0.3 this is like my
starting point for every learning rate
then I tweak that I play around with
that until I get the output that I want
and that's kind of how it works unless
you have a PhD and you know what you are
doing but that's how I do it well again
we have training session of 20,000
iterations and we say ok every time that
we activate our network with 0 and 0
I'm expecting a 0 0 1 I'm expecting a 1
and so for it and that will loop 20,000
times and I can't get it to work I can
do this is for example how it works it's
pretty fast it's a small example and you
can just play around with that like
saying 1 1 and I'll put some one yeah I
will upload the code for the examples
they don't make it her well yeah this is
how you can build a simple neural
network one thing that you might notice
is that all the inputs are 0 numbers
between 0 1 so if you want to use like
real data that you probably want to you
need to perform normalization that means
all your data should be mapped into
values between 0 1 I have example for a
but I had to cut that off so go to
synaptic they have a great guy that one
data normalization yeah there are some
other types of no networks we have
convolutional neural networks this error
mostly used for image recognition
because if you try to use a regular
neural network like this one like with
an image you will split the image into
pixels but then the neural network won't
have the context to make sense of those
those pixels because it needs special
con special context so that's why what
this neural network brings into into the
table you can see that link explains
everything pretty well this is based on
how the animals actually see pictures so
it's pretty interesting you are each of
those things then you have recurrent
neural networks
these are neural networks feeds
themselves with the there's their own
output so this is for trying to find
patterns on sequence of data basically
if you are like trying to teach the
neuron about the alphabet you will need
to know which there was before the one
that you are doing now and that's that
loop does that that gives that little
context then you have another type of
neural network that it's still recurrent
but this one keeps it just a gate
function on the neurons and it keeps
track of things that happened a long
time ago this is used when you want to
teach like a neural network to write
like Harry Potter you can make the nerve
like read all the books like 20,000
times and then it's going to remember
yeah so every five characters I use of
space I say Harry this many times
between each world and there are a lot
of cool experiment with that you can
just go into a lake and see there are a
lot of people doing interesting things
with this kind of network so I have a
couple of final notes this is like my
main note I experiment a lot with nodejs
and just with every model that I found
and I really like to encourage people to
do the same because I didn't knew that
we had so many
module for machine learning until I
started like Dignam on NPM so I think
everyone should just go and play around
with synaptic and you know make your
co-workers aware that that exists
because maybe they want to learn about
this and they don't want to run Python
or math or tensorflow
so now it's pretty cool and also there's
a quote that I heard on the yelling
curve a couple of weeks ago saying that
if you are employing people give you
should give them time to experiment
because otherwise that you're going to
expire in the production you don't want
that so that's uh no no no I know I
there are people that's concerned about
the performance of JavaScript in all
these things so my answer is check GPU
Jas hamster yes
G yes self-explanatory you can access
the CPU a GPU with JavaScript that solve
a lot of my problems with like huge
amount of training data I just connect a
GPU and you see if you don't have GPU
you can use hamster J's which is native
trading for node.js
that's also so a couple of problem for
me yeah if you want to play around with
neural networks and you don't know what
to do your labor is for IOT like
johnny-five Cylon and you can use that
as inputs on your own organic we're
things you know and there is robot J's
which is automation for the desktop on
ojs you know you can just feed a
recurrent neural network with the
movements of your mouse and try to
recreate your session I mean you can
experiment with a lot of modules so
that's pretty cool like last thing I
have a lot of meetings with clients that
they say yeah anyone this machine
learning algorithm to predict stock
trades or you know to be rich or
something it's like yeah up not rewards
I mean your plot when you're working on
machine learning your prog is not
actually the machine learning algorithm
because everything is open source
there are papers for everything if you
want to build a neural network that
learns to play music there is a paper
for that there is at least a hundred
guys that implemented that in different
ways so the price the data if you don't
have data the neuronal ways it's just
not going to work and it's going to work
poorly so if you are working on machine
learning things your real product is the
data my last advice follow this guy he
posts a lot of things before machine
learning for normal people like me so I
understand that so you can understand
that too so thank you for having me
[Applause]